today's Thursday April seventeenth and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters filling in for our Australian
team as they take a holiday to worship
the pantheon of poisonous animals that
runs their country and determines their
fates it's straight up mythical down
there now let's have some news the
ongoing debate about resolutions on the
Xbox one and the ps4 is part of a war
that is quotes unwinnable according to
titanfall producer drew McCoy McCoy said
there's going to be games that look
better on one or the other there's going
to be exclusives that look better for
whatever reason as for titanfall which
runs at a native resolution of 792 p
McCoy says no one in the office will
tell you we made the prettiest game out
there but he teased that they are
experimenting with ways to improve the
visual performance of titanfall what
strange and magical resolution will they
come up with next 808 p999 p a thousand
and one p sony announced today that
global sales of the playstation 4 have
exceeded 7 million units to paraphrase
andrew house president and group CEO of
sony computer entertainment we're so
excited you guys bought our stuff it's
tough to make enough stuff to satisfy
you stuff lovers but by golly we're
gonna get you that stuff and you're
gonna love it and we've got even more
stuff coming down the stuff pipe NPD
numbers are out this week so we'll soon
know how the Xbox one sales compared to
Sony's 7 million looking to the next
horizon of expensive electronics for you
to accidentally one click purchase sony
has announced its line of playstation
now ready for k ultra HD bravia TV sets
from 2099 dollars for a 49 inch TV all
the way up to twenty four thousand nine
hundred and ninety nine dollars for an
85-inch the line spans 94 k models they
are set to launch in june while the
playstation now streaming service is
scheduled to debut in summer 4k tvs
promised to deliver four times the
resolution of a 1080p set but is that
going to make your PlayStation 3 games
your streaming over PlayStation now look
a whole lot better have any of you even
seen a 4k set in action I have
nintendo passed up the opportunity to
partner with activision to make the
first Skylanders game a nintendo
exclusive according to a report by
polygon developer toys for Bob traveled
to Nintendo of America headquarters to
show off an early version of the game
where Nintendo said we've never seen
anything like this before and passed on
the game Nintendo did go on to make a
wii u eshop exclusive game using actual
figures called pokemon rumble you
meanwhile the Skylanders series is
currently worth about two billion
dollars think anyone got fired I think
someone might have umpires finally Sony
is considering offering a discount to
those who buy the last of us on
playstation 4 and already own the ps3
version of the game nothing concrete yet
but I for one would jump at the
opportunity to hop into some early
multiplayer matches on the ps4 version
and just do some brutal bandit murder
all over those wet behind the ears
do-gooder fireflies so many Molotov
that's the news for today see you
tomorrow when we round up our top five
stories of the week thanks for watching
and for all you viewers in australia all
glory to the platypus